but what's more likely peter you haven't
played this game yet we kind of have a a
selection of like the prices right type
games that we play and so what's more
likely today i'll throw out the
proposition and just to be clear you
there is no middle ground it's one or
the other a lot of times you're going to
be tempted to option c option d it's one
or the other and let's begin with this
one
what's more likely laramie tunzel stays
with the texans or jadavian clowney
stays with seattle chris sims what's
more likely okay what's the only lucky i
think oh that's the e that's the easiest
thing in the world it is the easiest
thing i said chris yes be quiet mr king
okay
i will go with uh laramie tunzel's thing
me pick me
with the texans is the one i would bet
on i mean yeah gideon clowning has got a
very real possibility of being a
one-year rental and it's a guy that we
talked about had micro fracture
surgery in his past so that's going to
scare teams the le the dolphins are
going to look stupid if they trade what
they traded for laramie tonsil and let
him walk out the door after one year
hey peter let me let me give it a little
twist okay because i think i know i know
what you've already tipped your answer
laramie tunsil and kenny stills stay
with the texans or jadavian clowney
stays with the seahawks what's more
likely there
tunsil and still stay with the texans
because i think once stills gets on this
team even though he's going to enrage
the flag waving fans of houston by
kneeling during the national anthem or
staying in the uh
locker room before the national for the
national anthem i think he's going to
become
a very reliable piece of that offense as
a third or fourth receiver he'll catch
45 balls he'll play 35 snaps every week
he'll practice every day he doesn't get
hurt and that is why i think he comes
back in 2020.
[Music]
uh and i agree with both of you i think
that that this is the no-brainer whether
it's tunsil alone or tunsil and stills
they have to keep these guys they've
given up too much to get them jadabi and
clowney very well may be a one-year
rental for the seahawks and the better
he plays for the seahawks the more
expensive he's going to be for the
seahawks right to keep him so the more
they would want him the more they're
going to have to pay to keep him in the
smart move for the seahawks would be
halfway through the season they decide
hey this guy's the real deal yeah maybe
you buy low before he really breaks out
in the postseason but i agree as framed
no-brainer tunzel stays with the texans
and throws stills in he stays two more
likely than clowney staying in seattle
all right next up we'll start with peter
what's more likely the chiefs return to
the afc championship game or the saints
return to the nfc championship game
what's more likely
well since i picked them both to make
the super bowl uh
i'm gonna say the chiefs anyway because
i picked the chiefs to win the super
bowl
um i just think right now
they are the most dangerous offense in
football mike i don't know i i'm sure it
has happened before
but i don't remember a team
that could have on on a given play on
the field at the same time
three
wide receivers who all ran under four
three five in the 40. right and adding
mccole hardman to watkins and hill i
just think how how possibly are you
going to cover all these guys now sammy
watkins obviously history of injury
right nicole hartman we just don't know
yet but i'm saying that potentially
this kansas city offense is going to be
impossible to stop yeah i'm i'm with you
there peter i'm going the chiefs if you
make me pick one i'm gonna go with the
cheese first off i just listen the
saints i really think they're gonna be a
really good football team i don't doubt
that i do wonder if they can bounce back
from the two years of heartbreak just
with that but i'm with peter's thought
of this offense in kansas city special i
mean it really is it has a chance to be
better than last year and now you adam
lashawn mccoy we know damian williams
peter mensah mentioned all the speed of
receiver he didn't even you know travis
kelsey's not even in that conversation
when you talk about that and then i do
think the defense it can only go up i
mean the defense stunk last year they
were horrible and i do think they they
made proper adjustments to their roster
along with spagnola as a defensive
coordinator so i go chiefs there all the
way
how big of a bump is the acquisition of
lashawn mccoy peter
i don't think he's going to be a
gigantic difference i think he's a nice
ad
but i think that at the end of the day
just my gut feeling that damian williams
is going to probably have more carries
than sean mccoy
yeah i think mccoy in my mind when i saw
that they got mccoy i mean that was the
one area where they had yet to fully and
confidently replace the kareem hunt
production damien williams has shown
some potential but you don't have that
same confidence in him you had to sean
mccoy to that mix with all the other
weapons they have and it made me think
and i already thought the chiefs were
going to get the afc championship game
now i'm rethinking whether or not i have
them going to the super bowl but i agree
with you guys the chiefs are more likely
to get to the afc championship than the
saints to the nfc championship i just
think that what the saints have gone
through the past two years having their
heart ripped out and stomped on twice
and and you throw on top of it peter and
you know chris and i've been talking
about this for the last eight months i
want your thought on whether or not you
think drew brees is maybe inching toward
the point where father time is going to
drag him down we saw some of that last
year are you concerned that drew brees
is maybe going to show signs of age this
season
you know you have to be concerned
anytime you pass 40
but i just look at him mike uh and i i
got a i got a very interesting podcast
dropping with him tomorrow and we talked
a little bit about that there's no
question in my mind that he wants to
play multiple more years
and the way the saints are operating i
wouldn't be surprised if they kept that
taysom hill security blanket around
and after this year let teddy
bridgewater go
but i just think this is a multiple year
situation febreze
and look there's no guarantee for
anybody there's no guarantee for brady
obviously at his age but
i just don't see it yet with breeze and
you know what mike one of the really
interesting things he told me in this
podcast
is
instead of going crazy and doing all
these funky uh new wave workouts
uh you know of 2019
i asked him what he did in the off
season he goes well you're going to like
this i spent the entire offseason
playing with my kids
tennis soccer football baseball it
doesn't matter we just played in the
yard and just played and he said it was
like i went back to the future that's
what i did when i was a kid and i come
into camp feeling fantastic we'll see it
probably means nothing
but he sounded to me like it's a lot
more likely he's gonna play three more
years than one
it's a big question i mean i i i'm gonna
be excited to see too because the saints
are a team that of course we're all in
the super bowl window conversation the
team around him certainly is good the
offensive coordinator and sean payton's
is one of the best there is there so i
don't think the numbers are certainly
going to fall off anytime
soon and i do think you know hey for
drew brees yeah 40 years old he's still
in phenomenal shape everything like that
the big question is going to be the arm
that's really all it's going to be i
mean it's gonna we saw it towards the
end of last year right guys we still
know he could be surgical it can be
accurate as can be can still move in the
pocket pretty well but can he back
defenses off and take advantage of some
of the big plays that are there to be
had especially when they're playing some
of the better teams in football you know
aka the eagles the first game of the
year i mean the first play of the
playoff game like you talked about mike
little plays like that uh i think that
showed their head last year that scare
us a little bit and that's when we'll
really be dissecting them this year
that's the thing i always uh think of
that that dialed up throw to ted ginn
first play from scrimmage they knew for
a week and a half that was the play and
he couldn't get the ball to ted ginn and
it was intercepted and it almost opened
the floodgates for the eagles to knock
them out of the postseason all right one
more before we break jacoby brissett
leads the colts to the playoffs or dak
prescott leads the cowboys to the
playoffs peter king what's more likely
jacoby brissette leading the colts to
the playoffs wow
i think that the
the supporting cast
of the indianapolis colts third best
offensive line in football last year
according to pro football focus uh a
vastly improved they could have three
new rookie defensive starters to a
really improved defense anyway by
mid-season
uh i i just think that this is a team
that he is not going to have to be what
he was in 2017
when he looked very mediocre jacoby
brissette has to be a piece in the piece
of the puzzle in 2019 i like the colts
to win that division
yeah i'm i'm going to go with dak
prescott on this one and you know and i
i look at i look at jacoby brissett and
the colts as being certainly in that
playoff conversation i i've done my own
little thing here i'm going to have the
colts not making the playoffs and i'm
going to talk about this later on my
podcast i got to see it to believe it
first as much as i like the
orchestration of that team i still look
at the dallas cowboys and i do think
ezekiel is going to be back here within
the next week or two if not the next day
or two to where i just go wow it's just
too talented of a football team for me
to leave them out of the playoffs
i mean uh really i mean the coaching
messes this up if dallas doesn't get
there now the colts the same way the
only thing i look at the colts is the
afc south is extremely hard right it's
very competitive division and mike i'm
gonna lean on something that you've
heard me say the last week or so since
andrew luck did this andrew luck's worth
two wins a year he's he's he's in the
conversation for the clutches
quarterback we've seen in the game
really last year and the year other
years he was healthy so i got to see
jacoby persette come through in those
moments to where they go with ten and
six instead of eight and eight you know
or they go 11 and five instead of nine
and seven whatever it may be so right
now if you maybe choose one of those i'm
gonna go with dak prescott and the
cowboys yeah i agree with with you chris
i go dak prescott and the cowboys i am
taking a a very measured approach with
the colts
fully cognizant of the possibility that
that the fact that they've fallen off
everyone's radar screen and andrew
luck's not there we just assume they're
not going to be good that plays right
into their hands they've got no
expectations right they're they're not
going to be that that team that that
other teams circle in ink on their
schedule that's the cults we're okay now
they don't have andrew luck and that
that is going to to i think give them an
opening but i'm not ready to buy it yet
between the two i'm gonna go dak
prescott in the cowboy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports